i'm told i don't know my staff keeps
these things secret from me but i'm told
that you have something special that you
wanted to do since this is
your last appearance on uh a nightly
show that i'm doing it's an emotional
thing for me and i'm well i got cordoned
in two weeks but i know what you mean
no no go ahead
this is a moment for me this is a moment
for me and i'm totally honestly
all kidding aside because i love dorazia
as you i know that's your expression but
um
you are one of the great brilliant
men of our era and i would say you have
influenced
more people in comedy that are
superstars today than
any human being you are adored and
worshipped
and i hope you understand that i don't i
don't
i don't but that's very nice
i know you don't agree but i switched
yes
and and and in all sincerity
may i say that that you are a true
original and i think
an original deserves an original so i
i penned a song just for you and i'd
i'd love to sing it that is if you'd
like
thank you so much
this is tough for me
there's only you
no one else can ever do
just what you do
if we could only have an hour more
or two you're the best
at what you do who else
can we turn to it breaks my heart
to have to say
marty marty yes
can you stop just stop the song for a
minute what's wrong
you don't like the song that i wrote for
you it's a great song
marty i i love the song it's just that
well we happen to have this can you play
a clip
from david letterman's last show
a couple of years ago can you you're the
best at what you do
who else can we turn to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much look at those guys
back there
well i do hit the exact same side
i hear certain similarities but
letterman is a titan of late night you
should be honored
this song is is for only the very best
the very best okay because you also sang
that song on the last episode
of the magic johnson talk show back in
the late 90s grow the clip
you're a legend
all the rest can just go
[Music]
well he really had an incredible 11
weeks
it wasn't just late night hosts it's
ridiculous he also sang this song
during the final episode of the jerry
springer show
there was
[Applause]
[Music]
blue
you sang a couple of months ago that
song
when mcdonald's announced they were
discontinuing
the shamrock shake
[Music]
is
it wasn't easy saying goodbye to that
one i'll tell you
i'm not gonna lie to you i love the song
but you've sung it to many people and a
milkshake
okay well regardless you deserve this
and of all the times i've sung this song
this time i'm on pitch because
only ones there only is
there's only one name in this biz
and now you're gone and i
am miserably blue
there's only you
you thank you conan
oh that's right you're still with me i'm
alive yes i'm alive
there's only
[Music]
thank you baby you're welcome
that's just crazy